washington d.c all 50 states are also on
high alert ahead of president-elect joe
biden's inauguration
our lead national correspondent david
begno is outside the state capitol in
lansing michigan
david good morning to you what are you
seeing there good morning there was
protesting at state capitals around the
country yesterday but no rioting
in fact where we are at the capitol in
lansing michigan there were more media
members and police officers
than people who actually showed up to
protest but the fbi says due to security
threats
don't let your guard down in the days
leading up to the inauguration two more
days to go
listen jeff told you more about what
happened inside the capitol on january
6th
i want to tell you more about the
arrests more than 120 people
who have been arrested thus far starting
yesterday with the county commissioner
from new mexico
his name coy griffin he posted videos of
himself
at the january 6th events and allegedly
pledged to return to dc
armed also arrested on sunday a man from
maryland
brian bettencourt a self-proclaimed
white supremacist
who posed at the capitol with a
confederate flag there's an affidavit
saying he was on parole for a burglary
and actually got permission to go to dc
for the riots but he told his parole
officer he was going there to distribute
bibles
a gps monitor tracking device told him
exactly where he was
and then there's the texas real estate
agent and so-called life coach jenna
ryan
she appears to have taken a private
plane to washington and
bragged about storming the capitol she
said they were armed and dangerous
then the fbi arrested her and now she's
saying this
me personally i do not feel a sense of
shame or guilt
from my heart from what i was doing i
thought i was following my president
i would like um a pardon from the
president
of the united states i think that we all
deserve a pardon we i'm facing prison
sentence
president trump is reportedly
considering issuing pardons
before he leaves office on january 6th
no telling whether or not he's going to
issue pardons for these folks but it
should be known
so many of them who were arrested on
january 6th
think they did absolutely nothing wrong
let's leave you kind of speechless david
thank you